savez vous que vous êtes un produit
alors je sais course de toujours
expliquer que vous étiez des humains en
fait un produit celui comptant et
surtout celui qu'on achète l'homme avec
un grand h conclure oui la femme l'homme
est un produit comme un autre alors je
vous imagine les gens vous diront
vieille et complètement taré il est
multiple ont été des premiers qu'en
baissant voulait s'acheter
oui vous êtes des produits je suis un
produit loeb un produit comme un autre
maintenant sur la zone chez darty à la
fnac sur le bon coin vous avez les pages
de produits
c'est pas raison un bon produit des
photos également des caractéristiques
imaginez maintenant votre cv ou votre
page linkedin il ya un mois et un prénom
vieilles photos puis à des missions
comme sur une page sur amazon ya des
avis a les références et dans les deux
cas et un prix pour vous c'est un
salaire l'homme est un produit
imaginez maintenant un produit pour
qu'on soit sur le même longueur d'onde
se produit ça respirateur
imaginez-vous maintenant prendre
quelques secondes et imaginez vous êtes
un aspirateur
qu'est-ce que vous avez imaginé vous
avez imaginé you de gamme du bas de
gamme
vous êtes plutôt du en dyson ou en pro
line d'être ouverts intermédiaire haut
de gamme
comment est ce que vous percevez quand
on vend un produit et qu'on est dans une
entreprise un produit
vous appelle du marketing pour le vent
c'est une cuisine quand on fait une
personne un institut ça s'appelle du
personal branding
c'est encore un mot anglais mais
personnalité qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est l'image de marque d'un bandit
c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi le business
du jeu
je suis vous êtes chez respirateur dyson
du pro line le business du jeu
c'est une façon de raconter une histoire
votre récit aux idées ce que vous avez
envie de faire partager aux autres
également
c'est de raconter la curiosité que vous
avez votre façon de vous projeter et de
communiquer au quotidien pour bien faire
le personal branding
il repose sur deux piliers et ses
piliers doivent être mis en avant mais
en action tous les jours
le premier c'est se projeter si vous
n'êtes pas capable de vous projeter
alors qu'est ce que vous allez raconter
quelle histoire vous allez être capable
de dire aux autres qu'est ce que vous
avez envie de leur dire pourquoi vous
faites ce que vous faites sur les
réseaux sociaux communiquer sur un blog
un site internet mais également dans la
paille
aujourd'hui si vous deviez avoir deux
supports de communication seulement 2
les indispensables dans l'apathie vous
devez avoir une carte de visite
parce que si vous ne donnez pas votre
numéro votre email
comment est-ce qu'on vous recontacte ont
croisé une personne à titre personnel ou
professionnel
ces personnes ne savaient pas elles ne
savent pas comment vous recontacter et
sur le web 2.0 sur le digital
cette carte de visite se transforme en
votre profil linkedin votre profil
linkedin c'est votre page produit c'est
vous digitalisées numérisés encore une
fois quand on va sur google si on vous
cherche qu est-ce qu on trouve le
personal branding permet d'imaginer la
curiosité de ce que vous allez trouver
quand on cherche votre coin profil en
charge jacqueline tine baun blog ou tout
ce que vous avez pu dire est recherché
prenez quelques
exemple de personnalités connues pour
que l'on puisse imaginer tout ça dans le
secteur de la grande distribution les
hypermarchés sont une concurrence assez
forte
et pourtant en début de semaine il y à
une marque qui est ressorti comme étant
la marque préférée des français devant
google c'est leclerc
j'ai envie de croire que michel edouard
leclerc qui est un personal training
très fort c'est à dire si une personne
qui sait gérer son image qui s'est
projetés dont nombreuses années qu'ils
se projettent sur la culture qui est
capable de vous dire sur son blog dans
des conférences
qu'est ce qui fait qu'il est pourquoi
comment la culture la politique
également
la culture est bien évidemment tout ce
qui touche au business de leclerc
michel-edouard leclerc en affaires un
article en disant nous allons est élu
marc de l'année première marque
il a écrit un article de blog ce 22 mars
mercredi et je vous en lien une partie
parce que ça aurait pu être très
clairement juste ma conférence sur le
personnel rising chef d'entreprise venez
mouiller la chemise aller dans les
médias à porter les valeurs de votre
marque faire connaître sa mission ses
métiers personne ne le fera pour vous
les français c'est encore une leçon de
ce placement aime les entrepreneurs
utile est proche
les français ont besoin d'entendre des
hommes et des femmes d'action qui
croient en l'avenir qui investissent et
créent les emplois au pays
montrez vos tronches montrer les bons
produits que vous créez défendez votre
utilité sociale
la réputation de aux marques y gagnera
et la reconnaissance de
l'entrepreneuriat aussi très clairement
michel edouard leclerc c'est se mettre
en avant
il sait il a des choses à dire et il est
dit il ya un peu plus d'un an
emmanuel faber qui est directeur général
de danone a fait une conférence devant
les étudiants de hec et il leur a
délivré un message ce message a été
diffusé sur facebook c'est une vidéo
d'une trentaine de minutes
cette vidéo elle a été relayée et vue
plus d'un million de fois
nathan la différence entre michel
edouard leclerc emmanuel
r c'est que d'un côté on a une personne
qui est présente
leclerc sur linkedin facebook twitter et
qui a un blog
de l'autre côté manuel s'avère rien pas
de facebook pas de twitter paul shin
devine pas de blog
on a une personne qui fait attention à
son personal branding à son image quand
on cherche on trouve
emmanuel faber il a par une page
wikipédia n'ya pas grand-chose savez que
c'est une personne qui arrive notoriété
mais qui ne s'en sert pas diffuser des
messages
et pour aller dire des choses à
l'extérieur peu importe qui vous êtes
si vous êtes salarié construisez notre
carrière sur quelques années sur 10 ans
15 ans 20 ans
projetez vous imaginez vous pourriez
être et vous avez beaucoup plus de
chances de l'être les menottes doré
c'est exactement ça vous allez un cdi
gagner de l'argent
pourtant vous fait pas plaisir c'est des
menottes elles sont belles il ya deux
personnes et les dirigeants les
dirigeants véhicules et la vision de
votre société
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de faire
paraître dans notre entreprise
les dirigeants ont en général une
aisselle mauvaise image de marque
et pourtant c'est un moyen d'humaniser
une personne et via les gens qui ont
déjà commencé le personal branding pour
eux des indépendants des start up et
toutes ces personnes se sont considérés
à un moment ou à un autre comme un
produit vous êtes des produits je suis
un produit
je m'appelle voyez j'ai ri je suis
entrepreneur les sportifs entrepreneur
c'est la façon dont je me présente
entrepreneur c'est la création de
sociétés la première sert l'éditeur
logiciel qui savent la clique toi libre
et la seconde c'est une agence de
communication vous l'auriez deviné dans
l'accompagnement d'individus dans le
personal branding
comment est-ce que j'en suis venu à ce
point on remonte quelques années en
avant
on est en juillet 2012 je suis en train
de faire du vélo en europe de l'est
je suis tout seul depuis une dizaine de
jours je fais 90 100 km par jour et je
suis en train de passer le budapest à
belgrade irait en novembre 2015
je suis dans un espace de coworking et
j'anime une conférence une formation sur
la performance commerciale et je
rencontre emile haag graphiste et là on
se rend compte tous les deux que on
partage un point commun c'est
l'accompagnement des personnes sauf que
lui il sait faire de l'image et moi je
vais faire des discours commercial à ce
moment ci banco di en fait l'un pour
l'autre
notre travail et on finit par faire par
une personne par une autre personne
l'année dernière on finit par paliers
vingt-et-une personnes et toutes ces
personnes sont des dirigeants
d'entreprise sont des sportifs connus et
derrière on a changé un petit peu leur
mouvement leur façon de se présenter et
leur façon de communiquer le personal
branding
ça sert à tout ça ça sert à s'imaginer à
se projeter habillez-vous pour le job
pour la mission pour le projet de demain
pas pour le job ou la mission que vous
avez aujourd'hui
projetez vous imaginez vous soyez
curieux haut rhin j'avais une conclusion
toute prête hier soir à 16 heures elle
le congrès pu et je vous faire confiance
j'avais traqué dans toute la semaine
difficile de dormir difficile de se
projeter
aujourd'hui et je me suis souvenu d'un
passage de l'écumé des jours de boris
vian et elle résume plutôt bien cette
situation et garder ça en tête
quand vous aurez des doutes j'ai le
sentiment que toute ma vie dépend de cet
instant précis si je rate personne lui
réponds moi je pense le contraire
si on rate ce moment on essaye celui
d'après et si on échoue on recommence
l'instant suivant
bon là toute la vie pour réussir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]